-Welcome to the show!
-I am so happy to be here.
Thank you.
-We're very happy to have you.
We do not -- You are the first
Supreme Court Justice
we've ever had on the show
This a big deal for us.
-Well, I hope not the last
-I hope not the last, too.
We've got eight to go.
[ Laughter ]
I want to ask, having Suprem
Court Justice in a family.
-Mm-hmm.
-Because obviously you have one,
do people ever in your famil
ask you to rule
on disagreements?
Is that something
that ever comes up?
-They did once.
How did that go --
Did they regret it in the en
that they asked you to rule?
-I regretted it.
-You regretted it, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-Nobody listened to me.
-Yeah.
And I would say,
in an interfamily,
if there was ever a time t
recuse yourself, it would be -
-That would be it.
-Yeah, that would be the time.
There are obviously a lot of
questions I'd love to ask yo
about things and goings-on
at the Supreme Court,
but you are not
in a position to answer them
and I am too stupid
to trick you into doing so
[ Laughter ]
But you can -- you can tell us
about your book.
So tell us about the story
and what brought you
to write this one.
-Well, the story,
and the line, "just ask,"
came from two separate
inspirations.
The writing of this kind of book
happened because the daughte
of a woman who worked with m
has an unusual
childhood condition.
And on occasion,
she would be sick
and would miss school
or activities
she wanted to engage in.
And once, she was
very sad about that.
sad about what she was
dealing with,
sad about the things
she would miss in life.
And her mother, by happenstance,
read her a children's book
not written by me, but about me.
At the end of reading it, sh
looked at her mother and said --
Now, mind you, most 5-year-old
can't say my name.
-Yeah.
-But her mom worked for me
so she could say my name.
"Justice Sotomayor,
she could do it with diabetes.
I can do it, too.
And I'm gonna do
exactly what she did.
I'm gonna to study hard
and not let this stop me."
[ Audience "aww"s ]
She's now 12.
-That's wonderful.
[ Applause ]
-The story -- The story create
two things in my mind.
The first is that children
with difficult circumstances
like hearing
that other people have made it
And so I knew there might be
some power to my story.
And so I first did a parent book
where I told more details
about my life story
and my dealing with my diabetes,
among many other things.
But I also knew
that I wanted to reach
all of those children
that have conditions
that they deal with
every day of their lives.
And just about everybody
knows a child like that,
whether it's something
like an allergy or asthma
or other things
that you can't see --
autism, attention deficit,
Down syndrome,
some of those you can see.
But there are
so many kids out there
who every day live with courag
and who add so much
to the quality of our living
And I wanted to be
a voice for them.
So I wanted to write a book,
but the title
and how it came to life
was something that had happene
to me over 30 years ago.
-Well, it's so wonderful
you did that.
And obviously, you have
such a unique story
among the many things
that are unique --
First Hispanic on the court.
And obviously, there have no
been a lot of women on the court
over the years.
[ Cheers and applause ]
You're also --
I mean, most importantly
for us here in the city,
you're from the Bronx.
-That helps.
And -- And while I do not
find this --
As a Red Sox fan, I find i
very distressing that you're -
-Ooh, I liked you until that
-Yeah, well...
Well, how do you think I fel
when I saw this photo?
[ Laughter ]
-You know --
[ Cheers and applause ]
-And it's nice.
Couple of judges from the Bronx.